oh my God
great question I don't care who this guy
is I just lost so much
a second chance
[Music]
let's talk about this movie man this is
a wild ride absolutely Wild Ride what
was the part of Scott's Journey that you
are most excited to explore and why I
think that I was excited to kind of
explore this whole thing he has going on
with Kang the Conqueror I knew about
King of the Conqueror I mean I knew even
as somebody who didn't read tons of
comics growing up I knew about Kang the
Conqueror that's how big of a villain he
is and so I knew Jonathan was going to
play him he's a great actor I and I
thought this is the third Ant-Man movie
but this is the baddest guy that we're
going up against ever you know
um and so this idea that Ant-Man was
going to go up against a villain that
was probably more powerful than Thanos
was a really interesting idea to me and
I was excited to see what that was going
to be like and as a result certain
aspects of Scott's personality come out
the tone of this thing is different just
because it's such a big huge movie
so yeah
I think I lost you on the audio but I
think I kind of got the gist of it yeah
oh no yeah yeah you froze for a second
but it's too bad because what I because
what I said was so interesting we'll
never get that back oh my God we'll send
you the transcript because it was I it
was you know it was just right there in
the air I don't even remember exactly
how I phrased it but it was perfect this
movie deals with time to an extent so if
you could go back in time and say yes to
a rule that you said no to previously
what would that rule be oh my God
a great question I think that the
success of some things has worked
because of the actors that actually did
it and not the not the fact that like I
didn't do it I haven't
there haven't been many things I turned
down they go ah you know I kind of move
on yeah there was one movie that I think
like well I maybe wish I had done that
one and it I don't want to say any
titles or anything like that but it was
a movie that involved uh some a few guys
that got um had a really crazy uh night
in Las Vegas ah well that's my hometown
I know what you're talking about all
right Paul thank you so much thanks a
lot
foreign
[Music]